[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mina kimes nfl analyst for the
mothership senior writer podcast host tv
contributor all-around good person 4
eastern on espn you can watch nfl live
with her with dan arlovsky marcus spears
laura rutledge ryan clark and keyshawn
johnson and mina kimese joins us on the
program mina best team in the afc is who
right now
the buffalo bills unless something crazy
happens tonight uh i'm riding with
buffalo and it's complicated there's so
much parody around the nfl right now but
they look like the most complete team
well i was wondering about the ravens of
what they're doing
not having you know any running backs
there what they did against the chargers
and and i know we always have this
referendum after every game it feels
like we know the team's either good or
not but where do the ravens sort of fit
in all of this
i've got them second and i'm so glad you
asked about the ravens in particular
because i just spent the morning
re-watching their defense that was by
far
the best game they put together on that
side of the ball and you know they've
struggled with some injuries obviously
losing marcus peters early in the season
was brutal in fact they're one of the
most injured teams in the league in
terms of players on ir but
you finally saw what a complete effort
could look like really they won in all
three shows beginning to shine elliot
back the safety was huge dan that might
be the worst game i've ever seen justin
herbert play as a pro and i've watched
all of them and a lot of it had to do
with the game plan put together by wink
barndale the ravens defensive
coordinator i mean he had no idea where
the pressure was coming from on third
down and watching them like we know what
lamar can do right we know he can put
the team on his back but watching them
yesterday against la i felt like for the
first time this team can actually win a
super bowl
really
yes wow
okay
i felt it i feel it what's your do you
disagree there's so much disbelief in
your voices now
oh i don't know i i think sometimes it's
uh you know it's like the declaration
last week was justin herbert i'd take
justin herbert over uh patrick mahomes
i'm like where did that come from
like you know we just we have these
statements sometimes and i just go wow
that might come back and haunt you
you know i think lamar what he's doing
in as far as value goes is is right up
there with with kyler murray he might
not have the numbers uh you know the
pretty numbers there but you know i'm
with you on on that team that coach and
what they did defensively was uh pretty
impressive but let me go back to justin
herbert and patrick mahomes
are are you on that hill are you going
to die on that hill justin herbert
all right no i didn't know that that i
mean i did i believe you when you say
that's the hill people are dying on
because you're such prisoners in the
moment and coming off of it's just been
such a wonky season with the chiefs and
a lot of that doesn't have to do with
patrick mahomes some of it does he he
made a pretty boneheaded made the most
fun had a mistake he's ever made
yesterday but
you got to look at the body at work
right i mean part of the reason
i'm so confident about lamar and the
ravens is at this point the dude's been
in the league for a few years right we
have the mvp season that everyone seems
to have collectively forgotten where he
was excellent throwing the ball whereas
again you know in herbert versus mahomes
i mean mahomes
yes he's had some ups and downs this
year yes the defense is terrible yes
he's made some weird interceptions and
uncharacteristically um i guess pressing
type throws but you can't compare
herbert to him yet after such small
sample size five teams are five
and one or better in the nfc so cards
cowboys packers bucks rams they went 5-0
in week six they won their games by an
average of 14 points per game if we were
going to rank these teams because we
always love rankings uh give me give me
one through uh five with those teams oh
lord okay so yeah okay there's five in
the nfc oh yeah because the rams okay so
are we ranking now or come january
january
oh god you got me okay so now everyone's
gonna mind me because i'm not gonna have
the cardinals number one they're
obviously number one now if you get to
six to no i don't care how you got it
greg joseph's miss field goals and chaos
and
all of that weird kick sixes you're sick
to know however if i'm gonna give you a
rankings in january and you come to
check back with me okay i'm going box
number one
i'm going
cardinals number two
um are you sure you believe that do you
believe that
i just don't want people to yell at me
okay so here's the thing about the
cardinals let me tell you why i have
cardinal skepticism even though i think
kyla murray is playing out of it he's in
god mode um
i was really hoping yesterday we would
get to see this defense tested against a
violent running game because i believe
that is the primary weakness of this
team unfortunately cleveland rolls in
with backup tackles and no nick chubbs
so that hypothesis is not tested and
really you can kind of throw out the
defensive poor performance to some
degree what kyler didn't often still
stand i'm very very intrigued by
cardinals packers in a couple of weeks
because i think that's going to be i
know the cardinals blew the rams out of
the water it was kind of a weird game
that got away from the rams early but
packers i think you know have the sort
of running game that can give the
cardinals the business and i still don't
trust cliff kingsbury in terms of game
management i mean it's incredible they
played pretty well without him but i i
just don't trust him particularly
compared to some of the other coaches at
the top of the nfc non-mike mccarthy
division are you all in on the cowboys
uh no because of the aforementioned mike
mccarthy aspect i am not um i think the
cowboys have the best offense in the nfl
i think they are a buzzsaw i think they
can beat you a million different ways
you see that whether it was the run game
the previous two weeks yesterday was the
past because new england was so
determined to stop the run but i think
this is a
yeah maybe above average defense now
that said i don't think there's we got
more parody in the nfl this year than
ever before so there's no you know
steamroller of a team that makes me
question the cowboys i just don't think
they're perfect i don't think they're
balanced to the degree that people seem
to think they are i know the rams won a
scrimmage yesterday with the giants but
true um
i i'm not sure
like what's the identity of this team
uh explosive
offense
with a little bit of
sprinkled in for matt stafford which you
kind of see pop up as a reminder that oh
yeah you still matt stafford and then
defensively um
two of the best players of their
generation and some weaknesses elsewhere
throughout um
actually not too dissimilar from the
packers to that scent with jared
alexander out but you are seeing a few
holes in this rams defense ranting out
against the giants that the cardinals
really expose where you can attack their
linebackers and all of the db's not
named jalen ramsey
who will be the all-pro quarterback in
the nfc this year
brady stafford
prescott murray rogers
other
i'm going jack price got there uh it's
really really hard since they're all in
the same conference as you just
described but
it's funny because that's not my mvp and
when i say my mvp i think with you at
the way that you do dan where i'm
looking at actual value to the team
which is why i'm rolling with lamar but
i think dak is not only playing at an
extraordinarily high level he's part of
an offense in terms of the line the
skill players by the way michael
gallup's going to come back at some
point and then a play caller that's
going to ensure he has this level of
success for the rest of the season
talking amina kimes the analyst senior
writer podcast host tv contributor for
the mothership
what was your super bowl pick and do you
want a do-over
i think i had the bucks
chief
really original right um
and right now i'll go
book spills
okay
so that means the bills will lose
tonight
yeah if the if the bills lose tonight
can you who's producing this can you go
and delete the sort of archives
mean i'd be really shocked and if they
do lose tonight by the way the afc is
total chaos right i mean i we're all
kind of
coming out of last week saying okay the
bills look finally this looks like an
actual balance team we know what they
can do on offense in terms of their five
power but the defense was untested going
into last week they played a cupcake
schedule
pass rushers look great we know how good
the safeties are and today is white and
suddenly i think that those questions
have evaporated
if they lose to the titans then i i
don't know what to believe anymore my
entire belief system will be thrown into
question
you tweeted this out last year tom brady
35th and passer rating went pressured
this year he's second how do you explain
that oh chaos bob um
it's complicated because if it was just
this year versus last year i would say
it's mostly scheme comfort within the
offense right and i think that does
explain a lot of it uh but
as you guys remember i'm sure locally
tom brady also struggled against
pressure in his final years in new
england too it's a lot of that had to do
with the skill players and their
inability to separate i think that's an
important part of explaining why but um
the dude is playing the best football
he's played in years at the moment and
it seems like a perfect storm of reasons
ranging from scheme to the personnel
around him to the man himself
yeah i'm just trying to understand why
he would walk away and the only thing i
could think of was
that he comes to the realization about
missing out on things at home
that because other than that it's not
like he's he was fast enough to slow
down and if he still has a good arm good
protection he likes the coach likes the
system likes the weather uh got some
skill position players
why would tom brady walk away
you know i always thought brady would
walk away because he was tired of
getting hit let's just see maybe that's
a very normal way to look at it where
you kind of put yourself into this shoes
of a man who's accomplished everything
and treats that will probably never be
matched right but i thought man you know
i'm younger than tom brady but even me
if i stubbed my toe in the corner of the
bed the day is over i'm watching him get
hit in the pocket i'm like you don't
want to do this anymore and then the
statistic you just read out loud well
he's throwing pearls while he's getting
hit this year and that is different than
from the previous two years and
i i
seth wickershim who i'm sure you've had
on your show he's got this new book on
the past right he was telling me the
other day that brady practices taking
sacks which is true sicko behavior
explains the greatness but watching him
this year he he really even when he's
getting hit there's sort of like an
elegance to it an ability to rip off
these throws that again makes me agree
with you i i really don't understand why
he'll walk away at this point given not
only the level of football he's playing
but the nature of it good luck to your
bills tonight mina great to talk to you
again
prayers prayers up bye guys mina cox
espn nfl analyst senior writer podcast
host tv contributor